[Música]
[Aplausos]
hacer vídeos es mi fuerte y entonces
antes de presentarme en frente a ustedes
lo cual me pone muy nerviosa quería
contarles un poquito de mí no así en
vídeos que es lo que hago así que
[Música]
ah
para empezar quiero contarles que tengo
un trabajo muy cool y yo pensé que por
tener un trabajo muy cool que me hace
muy feliz se va a acabar rapidísimo no
solo yo pensaba eso todas las personas
en alrededor lo pensaban también no
creían en wind pero éste hola a todos yo
soy daniel oss tengo 23 años y se queda
de contenido digital desde que soy
chiquita así descubrí que dibujara lo
que más feliz nacida de verdad no tiene
una idea yo muñecas no siempre dibujar y
por alguna extraña razón y muy muy muy
buena mis papás que son ellos y apoyaron
mi decisión de ser artista crean en mí
este no les importó que quise hacer
artes y todo eso entonces cuando yo
empecé a subir contenido las redes
sociales me daban mucho me costó
muchísimo explicarles cómo funcionan las
redes sociales pero
y creo que deberían haber más papas así
en el mundo de los que apoyan los sueños
de los hijos
esta soy yo a los 17 años y cuando viven
prepara tenía un sueño enorme que era
inspirar a la gente con mi arte con mis
dibujos entonces pues esto empezó cuando
conocí la fabulosa plataforma instagram
yo me sentía muy feliz porque era un
espacio en donde yo podía expresarme
libremente podía subir mis dibujos los
podía compartir a muchas personas y esas
personas se sentían identificadas
conmigo y yo con ellas no había nada de
puebla nadie conocido o nada asignada
entonces yo era muy contento muy gentil
y yo tenía una meta si inspirar a una
sola persona con mis dibujos ya cosa gol
de por vida y lo logré ese día fue una
persona de aquí inspiré que me dijo que
con mi dibujo se ponía feliz en las
mañanas dos aquí ya despertaba veía mis
dibujos y la alegraba el día este día
era una persona hoy son casi dos
millones de personas que sienten eso
conmigo
ahora tal vez sus sueños no sean los
mismos que los míos pero yo los quiero
convencerla de hoy decidir sus pasiones
de seguir sus sueños y de echarle todas
las ganas yo en lo personal he cumplido
sus sueños que nunca imaginé que iba a
poder tener por ejemplo uno de mis
sueños cumplidos fue que youtube me
premiará por tener un millón de
seguidores con una placa así
también
pintar un contenedor en chapultepec
también es ser parte de los kids choice
awards cuando yo de chiquita había los
títeres aberdeen dios mío nunca pensé
ser parte de eso pero después que el
disco vélez y me invitara ocean blue me
invitaba muy a ver sus murales en la
ciudad y locura salir en el comercial de
vodafone por cierto si lo vieran yo soy
la que y también salir en una botella de
buena forma cool y trabajar de la mano
con uno por la igualdad de género
en el programa
y pintarán están súper muy como ya lo
pudieron ver entonces tarde estos sueños
no son los mismos que los míos yo lo sé
y noté que para presumirle se los juro
solamente es para que vean que cuando se
cuando uno cuando sigue estos sueños de
verdad hay cosas que no te esperas no te
imaginas yo nunca me imaginé poder
cumplir esto ahora vamos a un ejercicio
todos quiero que piensen en algo que
podrían hacer todos los días si un joven
que podríamos ver todo hacer no se vale
ver netflix no sabe dormir estos están
descalificados pero eso que podrías
hacer todos los días
como lo vamos a hacer o sea que en medio
vamos a escoger para convertirlo en tu
trabajo tu hobby el medio su felicidad
entonces en mi caso fue dibujar y el
medio por las redes sociales y hoy en
día me despierto encantada para trabajar
entonces tienen que hacer esos chicos
ahora
como todo en la vida hay obstáculos y yo
les voy a platicar ahorita los tres
obstáculos que yo pues me topé sino que
haber contenido distante
ahí están gente mala onda
es el primero la gente mala onda siempre
te va a ver como el raro y a la
gente mal onda me encanta hablar mal del
raro de sassima entonces lo que ya
aprendí pues gracias a mi ídolo llamado
que hice y mainat que es un creador de
contenidos
pero él dice que los hitler al users
under email users el camino dice que los
genes algo vintage
como la canción de taylor swift giro en
gente ya sabe el panameño el caso es que
el 50 es palabras y tiene toda la razón
es muy fácil ser cutter es muy fácil ver
las cosas malas de los demás sus
defectos y juzgar criticar es facilísimo
o no pero es muy difícil crear tener una
idea ejecutarla y compartirla eso es lo
difícil entonces cuando el hermano hacía
esto que dice que disney that me quedó
claro y yo quería hacer una creadora y
no quiere ser un hater y gracias a él me
quedé con esto y lynch willis y heming y
su the hurt locker suena que adoran una
gente y por eso los haters ya no me
afectan hoy en día
en la número dos de obstáculo es la zona
de confort como en cualquier trabajo la
zona de confort te puede llevar a
hundirte horrible ok
resulta que yo llevo con este trabajo
super cool de 4 años y me topé con esta
al menos en mi don de confort hace un
año yo me despertaba aburrida sin ganas
pero sabía que tenía que hacerlo sabe
que tiene que serlo porque mi trabajo
esta es una captura de pantalla de hace
un año vídeos medio feliz me veo en los
tests observen de allí pero yo en
realidad estaba muy aburrida de lo que
hace la base a todos los días de no las
de aportación ya lo dibujaba por amor ya
no dibujaba por nada más dibujaba para
presentarme a trabajar también entonces
me di cuenta que no podía permitirme a
mí mismo después de tanto esfuerzo tanto
desvelada tanto todo está en una zona de
confort y de repente cambie
mi época de ahorita unos meses para
atrás no sé o si yo me conozco a ustedes
igual y no sé pero bueno aquí yo estoy
feliz aquí yo estoy muy encantada con el
trabajo contenta y genuinamente feliz
haciendo lo que me apasiona entonces
nunca estén razones conjunto que después
en una creces la indisciplina la somos
cinco indisciplina eso sí en cualquier
trabajo
nada nada te va a llevar al éxito si
eres una persona institute nada y creo
que más como creador de contenido ok el
internet es
extremadamente gigante amigos demasiado
y es tan grande que tú como creador de
contenido y creador de contenido pues si
no te presentas un día a trabajar porque
es un trabajo alguien puede llegar a
reemplazarlos si un día no apareces en
las redes sociales es tan grande el
mundo que una persona puede llegar a
tomar tu lugar porque igual y hacéis el
mismo contenido de igual y tiene música
más padre igual y su vídeo está mejor
producido editado entonces como creador
de contenido tienes que ser disciplinado
tienes que trabajar todos los días
presentarte y hasta en días festivos
entonces esas fotos en lo que tenemos
creo que es muy cool de verdad usar tu
vida y hacer algo que amas todos los
días yo me pongo a pensar en las
personas que de verdad se despiertan y
hacen algo que no les gustan que no les
gusta estudiar en algo que no les
apasiona tuvieron que hacerlo por sus
papás por las por no sé lo que sea
pónganle x norma busca juzgar a nadie
gritar
pero creo que esto no está cool venimos
de esta vida para hacer de nuestros días
los más felices y si no haces algo en
todo tu día de trabajo que no te va a
ser feliz
no importa hazlo cambiarlo hazlo busca
acuerdo de 6 tu hobby el medio y tu
trabajo
y lo dejó con esta bonita frase
[Música]
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]